bonsoir nous sommes le 14 avril 2016
bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 pour faire le
tour de l'actualité locale voici les
principaux titres ac après la diffusion
d'image de maltraitance dans un abattoir
des pyrénées atlantiques l'état entend
renforcer les contrôles nous sommes
allés rencontrer les responsables du
dernier site encore en activité dans les
yvelines située à houdan à 2016 marquée
par les cinq ans de la catastrophe de
fukushima et les 30 ans de la
catastrophe de tchernobyl ce samedi le
collectif sortir du nucléaire organise
une nouvelle marche de sensibilisation
sur saint quentin en yvelines pour en
parler olivier paréja élus europe
ecologie les verts est membre du réseau
les féminines de montigny le bretonneux
handball devrait connaître une
relégation en nationale 2 à l'issue de
la saison le point avec l'entraîneur
bruno philippe présent lui aussi sur ce
plateau tout à l'heure
manuel valls en déplacement ce matin
dans les yvelines depuis monte la jolie
et le premier ministre est venu annoncer
les priorités 2016-2017 du plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté et pour l'inclusion
sociale on retiendra la nouvelle hausse
du rsa + 2 % en septembre pour la
quatrième année consécutive le
gouvernement entend revaloriser le rsa
de 10% en cinq ans et d'ici à 2017 en
plus de l'inflation
le 29 mars dernier l'association de
protection animale l214 a dévoilé des
cas de maltraitance dans un abattoir bio
du pays basque avec des images
particulièrement choquant
suite à ces révélations stéphane le foll
le ministre de l'agriculture a ordonné à
tous les préfets de france de procéder à
des inspections dans l'ensemble des
abattoirs et du pays nous avons voulu
savoir comment était encadrée justement
le dernier abattoir porcin d'île de
france il est située située à houdan
camille lambert entre 2500 et 3000 porcs
sont abattus chaque semaine dans ses
locaux situés à houdan l'abattoir
guillard ans est le dernier
établissement de ce type en
ile-de-france depuis 2013 les normes
européennes du bien-être animal ont été
renforcées vincent hareng directeur de
l'abattoir yvelinois s'assure du respect
de ces règles
mettons les ports par deux dans des
ascenseurs ils descendent dans une
concentration à 90 % de co2 qui les
endort immédiatement une fois que donc
les cochons dorment complètement
ils sont saignés donc nous on récupère
le sens et après sa part sur la chaîne
d'abattage une machine validé par la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations et par une
association de protection animale mais
les vidéos publiées sur internet en
octobre 2015 par l'association l214 ont
incité l'abattoir à prendre de nouvelles
mesures
depuis les premières vidéos donc nous
avons bien regardé tout ce qui aurait pu
ne pas aller donc maintenant notre taux
de co2 était avant affiché sur une
petite affiche maintenant c'est une
grosse lumière verte rouge si sévère on
peut tuer si c'est rouge on arrête tout
parce que l'animal risque de ne pas être
assez endormie selon vincent hareng les
abattoirs n'ont aucun avantage maltraité
un animal le stress et la souffrance
altère la qualité de la viande et
entraîne donc des pertes financières
l'établissement de 90 salariés fait
l'objet d'un contrôle annuel complet en
plus d'un contrôle quotidien de la ddpp
une équipe de 5 personnes en permanence
qui j'allais dire ça se fait
régulièrement l'abattoir deux axes
principaux la protection animale
vérifiez donc si les animaux qui
arrivent à l'abattoir donc des ports
c'était un match uniquement de porcs ne
sont pas blessés ne sont pas malades et
bien entendu la sécurité sanitaire des
aliments
en cas de non respect des lois en
vigueur les établissements sont
sanctionnés des peines pouvant aller
jusqu'au licenciement du salarié
concerné ou la fermeture de l'abattoir
après la nouvelle publication d'une
vidéo de l214 fin mars
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture a ordonné aux préfets de
procéder à des inspections dans
l'ensemble des abattoirs du pays
elles doivent être réalisés avant la fin
du mois d'avril
mais nous suivons bien évidemment ce
dossier les prochaines visites
programmées c'est bientôt l'été et les
étudiants sont en pleine recherche de
jobs saisonniers certains souhaitent
financer tout simplement leurs vacances
d'autres c'est une recherche de première
expérience professionnelle
pour les aider dans cette recherche
plusieurs dispositifs se met en place
c'est le cadre des bureau information
jeunesse attrape mais aussi du
département des yvelines qui propose des
emplois pour aider les seniors isolés
fanny bourdillon fait le point trouver
un job d'été est souvent synonyme de
difficultés pour les jeunes du
département
pourtant de nombreuses entreprises sont
en train de recruter c'est le cas du
dispositif yvelines étudiants seniors du
conseil départemental
chaque été depuis la canicule de 2003 il
recherche 150 jeunes pour aider les
seniors les plus isolées on recherche
157 dian pour cet été pour rendre des
visites de convivialité
nos personnes âgées isolées sur tout le
département
donc concrètement on a lancé une grande
campagne de candidature et il faut se
rendre dans les coordinations
gérontologiques de chaque territoire
et puis on pose un cv ou candidates
et puis si on est retenu on passe une
petite journée de formation et ensuite
on est envoyé pendant tout l'été sur le
terrain et si l'aide à la personne ne
vous attire pas d'autres secteurs
recrutent transport restauration rapide
ou animations ainsi c'est une quinzaine
d'entreprises qui était présente ce
mercredi à trappes
le bureau information jeunesse de la
ville organise chaque année à la mi
avril un forum jobs d'été
on est le premier échelon j'espère car
nombreux jeunes qui vont trouver en fait
un emploi mais c'est aussi pour leur
dire voilà même si vous trouvez pas ici
c'est le moment de chercher parce que
les tarifs très très vite et c'est pas
au mois de juin qu'on va commencer à
réfléchir à son emploi saisonnier c'est
vraiment des mars avril
c'est le cas de cech trappistes de 21
ans il étudie l'administration a lu vs
cul et souhaite trouver un job d'été
dans son domaine donc c'est sûr une
essence donc c'est vraiment ton coeur de
métier au niveau de la licence ça te
permet d'avoir au delà des aspects
théoriques d'avoir une vraie
connaissance pratique quoi moi c'est là
que j'ai commencé à rédiger le premier
cv la lettre de motivation savoir cours
ou postuler et c est
vraiment je crois une difficulté ses
sculptures et c'est vraiment une chance
qu'on connaît tous le monde pourront
nous aider pour d'autres c'est
l'occasion de se faire une première
expérience professionnelle ou
d'économiser de l'argent pour partir en
vacances pour juillet pour pouvoir me
payer mes vacances en août c'était déjà
venu il ya deux ans et j'avais rien
trouvé parce que c'est vrai qu'il faut
quand même avoir 18 ans la plupart du
temps et donc la ville j'ai eu 18 ans et
je trouve ça super que la mairie trappe
organise ce genre de forum pour les
jeunes quand on voit son concours aux
généralement nous demande si on a déjà
d'expérience avec les enfants donc là si
j'ai un boulot avec les enfants ça
pourra toujours méditer
munis d'un cv et d'une lettre de
motivation c'est le moment ou jamais
pour ces jeunes de postuler en ligne ou
de répondre aux annonces papier 2016
marquée par les cinq ans de la
catastrophe de fukushima et par les 30
ans de celle de tchernobyl le réseau
sortir du nucléaire poursuit son
objectif d'obtenir l'abandon du
nucléaire en france et organise
notamment chaque année une marche en
mémoire des victimes plusieurs
rendez-vous à travers la france et
notamment ce samedi 16 avril à 11 heures
à saint quentin en yvelines les
sympathisants du réseau vont déposer une
gerbe de fleurs devant les locaux
d'areva à montigny le bretonneux olivier
paréja bonsoir vous êtes membre de ce
collectif est également élu militants
europe ecologie les verts il y à aussi à
vos côtés des membres d'attac de
greenpeace du parti de gauche notamment
peut-être un mot déjà sur cette
opération est symbolique qui va se
dérouler samedi matin comment doit se
dérouler l'opération et puis pourquoi
cette opération alors pourquoi cette
opération vous l'avez dit 1 c c'est
cette année marque les 30 ans de la
catastrophe de tchernobyl les cinq ans
de fukushima et c'est une opération que
nous renouvelons absolument tous les ans
de façon à continuer à montrer qu'il ya
une opposition à rester dans le
nucléaire tel qu'il est aujourd'hui en
france vous allez déposer ensuite une
gerbe devant les locaux d'areva voilà
donc on aura une courage de l'an dernier
exactement donc l'idée c'est de d'avoir
un moment de
d'hommage aux victimes du nucléaire mais
aussi aux travailleurs du nucléaire qui
sont qui sont aussi des travailleurs qui
sont dans des conditions précaires et
dont le statut ne permet pas de les
défendre devant les problèmes sanitaires
qui peuvent être liés à leur travail
concernant tchernobyl fukushima
vous dites que la catastrophe se
poursuit il ya eu ces deux catastrophes
mais les conséquences encore se font
ressentir alors déjà il ya tout le monde
je pense c'est aujourd'hui que les
conséquences exactes des catastrophes
sont pas connues mais il ya des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont été déplacées il ya des centaines de
milliers de victimes et des des effets
sanitaires sur l'ensemble de l'europe
clairement pour pour ce qui concerne
tchernobyl et fukushima aujourd'hui
c'est encore près de 8 % du territoire
japonais qui est considéré comme comme
contaminé et sur lesquels on peut pas on
peut pas vivre donc cesser ces
catastrophes c'est pas simplement un
accident un instant t tout ce qui
concerne le nucléaire et on reviendra
peut-être sur le problème des déchets
c'est des choses qui durent des
centaines de milliers d'années et donc
la contamination n'est pas quelque chose
qui s'arrête le lendemain de la
catastrophe
le réseau sortir du nucléaire existe
depuis 1997 l'ambition c'est de se
tourner vers des alternatives en termes
d'énergie quelles sont ces alternatives
possibles
aujourd'hui on commence à aider des gens
qui sont pas du tout écologiste 1 prenez
par exemple la banque lazard qui ne peut
pas quand même être considéré aux états
unis comme une officine d'écologistes
reconnaît que l'efficacité des nouvelles
énergies comme le solaire comme l'éolien
est meilleur que le nucléaire que le
coût du kilowattheure si on intègre à
l'intégralité de la filière c'est à dire
à la fois l'extraction de l'uranium
on nous parle des nez de deux dents
dépendance énergétique mais l'uranium il
n'ya pas absolument pas d'uranium en
france la plupart de l'uranium dans le
monde et est fait dans le caza est
produit dans le kazakhstan donc entre
l'extraction la production et le
recyclage des déchets le coût est
nettement plus important pour de
l'électricité produit au nucléaire donc
en france où on est dans une situation
où les trois quarts de l'énergie
électrique pas de notre énergie globale
mais de l'énergie électrique sont
produits par le nucléaire
nécessairement on peut pas du jour au
lendemain basculer sur une autre
solution c'est évident mais par contre
ce qui est important
ce qu'on peut attendre des pouvoirs
publics c'est de donner l'orientation la
loi de transition énergétique voter en
allez déjà dans le sens de d'inciter à
réduire la part du nucléaire en france
fermer fessenheim par exemple donc ça
c'est des choses sur lesquelles il faut
aller pour donner le sens donné des
investissements dans tout ce qui peut
être énergies renouvelables et il y en a
de nombreuses façons dans l'actualité il
ya eu justement un écho à ce que vous
nous dites c'est aujourd'hui les trois
quarts notre électricité on le rappelle
qui proviennent du nucléaire y avait
cette promesse de françois hollande de
réduire cette part de 50% en 2025 ce mot
sur les réacteurs a fermé les décisions
viennent d'être portées à 2019 par
ségolène royal au total février cette
nouvelle abbas est absolument pas du
tout ce vers quoi on voudrait étendre
une même nos voisins
si on prend le luxembourg s'est plaint
que la centrale de cattenom qui était à
côté de chez eux était un danger pour
leur territoire et que si un incident se
produisait le luxembourg serait rayé de
la carte
l'allemagne protestent contre la même
centrale de fessenheim qui est une des
plus anciennes et qui serait logique de
fermer aujourd'hui sur 58 réacteurs
nucléaires en france il pratiquement la
totalité vont passer les 30 ans aurait
été conçu pour durer trente ans il va
falloir investir des milliards pour
arriver à les maintenir plus longtemps
il est temps que et en particulier c'est
ce qu'on peut attendre du gouvernement
que on donne l'impulsion pour se tourner
vers autre chose
vous êtes aussi membre d'europe écologie
les verts emmanuelle cosse l'ancienne
patronne d'europe écologie les verts est
au gouvernement
et lorsque vous entendez genre de
mesures eh ben je comprends que relever
le col du tout partie d'europe écologie
les peuples a dit en venir je pense que
c'était une réflexion individuelle on va
dire l'ensemble du mouvement et n'était
pas pour aller au gouvernement donc elle
a fait un choix personnel qui n'engage
pas l'ensemble des militants qui
maintiennent qu'il faut sortir du
nucléaire et bien d'autres choses mais
en fin de sujet ce soir
toujours par rapport à l'actualité et la
construction de cette paire de
flamanville dans la manche le prototype
du réacteur de nouvelle génération qui
se déroule en ce moment
edf et areva qui annonce des tests
supplémentaires puisque aujourd'hui la
cuve du réacteur qui présenterait un
défaut c'est absolument dramatique
industriellement c'est complètement
dramatique
areva est en train de perdre des
millions
et du retard de plusieurs années en
finlande sur l'autre br / celui de
flamanville on est passé d'un coup qui
était de 3,5 millions on est passé à 8
donc les échelles sont complètement
modifié et la maintenance s'aperçoit
qu'une cuve mais une cuve qui a été
fabriqué il ya je ne sais plus une
dizaine d'années quelque chose comme ça
donc si on doit la refaire ça prend un
retard phénoménal
et qu'est-ce qu'on va dire à la fin que
finalement les fissures les tests de
matériaux dans la cuve ne sont pas si
grave est-ce qu'on va prendre ce risque
là il ya une vraie inquiétude à avoir
sur la filière nucléaire en france c'est
à dire que on voit que c'est un fiasco
économique
le directeur financier d'edf a dénoncé
les contrats avec l'angleterre il il ya
vraiment quelque chose où on peut
trouver qu'on est plutôt dans
l'entêtement idéologique a continué sur
cette énergie là que à l'ouverture et au
fait que l'on pourrait peut-être penser
à d'autres énergies
donc il y aura cette marche pour lutter
contre le nucléaire pour sortir du
nucléaire est aussi en mémoire des
différentes victimes que ce soit
tchernobyl ou fukushima ce sera samedi
16 avril à partir de 11 heures une
dernière question quels sont les autres
actions qui sont menées par le collectif
sortir du nucléaire au quotidien on vous
entend chaque année sur cette marche
mais tout au long de l'année bas par
exemple quelque chose qui touche aussi
les yvelines c'est les les trains qui
transportent des déchets nucléaires pour
aller se faire retraités à la hague
ces trains circulent au milieu des voies
au milieu des trains de voyageurs à des
heures par exemple à la gare de chantier
il arrive que vers 7 heures le matin il
y ait des trains qui transportent des
déchets nucléaires qui traversent des
villes sans que les autorités locales
que ce soit les maires que ce soit les
préfets ne soit au courant
donc là aussi il n'y a rien à des
mobilisations du réseau sortir du
nucléaire par exemple pour dénoncer ce
fait et le fait que ça devrait pas
passer à des heures où il ya du monde et
sur des voies utilisées aussi par des
trains de voyageurs surtout à des heures
de pointe merci olivier par hadja et
donc samedi 16 avril à 11 heures en
direction des locaux d'areva à montigny
le bretonneux merci à vous dans le reste
de l'actualité un mot d'éducation il met
à profit ses leçons mathématiques ou de
physique ce sont les élèves du collège
de la shoah et long cours qui
participent à robot éthique c'est un
projet qui a été lancé dans les yvelines
par les yvelines
roy collège yvelinois vont s'affronter
dans un challenge inter établissements
ce sera au mois de juin
problème technique numéro de monsieur
vous avez ici un capteur de lumière
d'accord ce capteur il n'est pas
positionné d'origine sur le robot ses
élèves de 4e du collège de lajo
d'elancourt relève chaque semaine les
défis robotique lancé par leurs
professeurs
trois équipes réalisent chacune un robot
il ya déjà au parti créativité voilà ce
qu'on leur demande de concevoir quelque
chose on c'est sûr qu'ils commencent pas
de zéro on part sur une base déjà
existantes mais il ya des modifications
à faire et il ya des réflexions et des
problèmes techniques à résoudre
donc il ya des compétences qui vont
plutôt s'orienter vers le cours de
technologie mais il ya aussi des
compétences d'ordre mathématique puisque
de la programmation à faire pour
robotique projet lancé par le
département des yvelines les collégiens
réalise des robots autour du thème du
sport chaque équipe est composée d'un
reporter de programmateurs et deux
constructeurs
d'après une pièce enfin en forme de t
qui a servi à les mettre sur les vues
sur la peau ce qui quand la boule à
vivre elle soit agrippé qu'il puisse
partir avec la bosse je programme un peu
les actions qu'il doit faire que les
robots doivent pas faire
par exemple par exemple avec sa curie
peut donner des coups il peut avancer
reculer
on n'a pas encore testé de le faire
tourner mais on va bientôt le faire dans
deux mois leurs robots devront suivre
une ligne tenir une balle ou donné un
coup dans un objet les collégiens
rencontreront leur concurrent dangereux
et de bennes pour un challenge le 13
juin prochain vie locale le projet des
fresques duval hibou qui suit son cours
hier après-midi avait lieu une réunion à
la maison à des familles la mosaïque de
plaisir pour présenter les premières
réalisations artistiques et les
démarches créatives
rappelons que huit façades d'immeubles
seront décorés elles ont été choisies en
fonction de leurs positions stratégiques
afin que les fresques soit visible par
le plus grand nombre
si tes créations qui est en charge du
projet s'est inspiré des témoignages des
photos et des demandes envoyées par les
habitants ce qui est ressorti beaucoup
c'est la diversité des couleurs à la
profusion des couleurs la profusion
aussi des rythmes d énergie on a eu
beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
d'interviews au delà des échanges
voilà dans le cadre de ses ateliers avec
les habitants on a eu beaucoup de vidéos
qui nous ont été transmises on a eu des
comptes on a eu des témoignages des
histoires plein de photos donc on a
essayé de ceux de s'imbiber tout ça est
un moment pour faire notre travail
d'artiste de designers artistes peintres
il faut qu on s'extrait de tout ça pour
se projeter
prochain rendez vous en juin lors du
festival escales d'ailleurs cité à
création présentera les skis sous forme
de maquette à tous les habitants de
plaisir le début des travaux ce sera
pour la fin de l'année 2016 nous passons
aux sports a présenté le jeudi c'est
avec mais quel ennemi d' eurobonds soir
qu'elle est avec votre invité nous
allons parler de handball handball
féminin voilà aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de handball féminin les joueuses
de montilly retenus sont dans une
spirale négative dans le championnat de
national
une les imans thann se sont inclinés à
domicile contre pessac et sur le score
de 22 à 21 au classement les joueuses de
bruno philippe se dirige tout droit vers
la descente en nationale 2 en fin de
saison pour nous parler de montigny nous
recevons sur ce plateau le coach bruno
philippe pour le philippe seydoux
inquiet après cette défaite contre
pessac et c'est d'abord bonsoir oui bien
qu' on est toujours un petit peu inquiet
mais ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est
la blessure de fanni jean baptiste qui a
été je vais pas dire sauvagement agressé
mais agressé donc et qui est blessé
lourdement et on va devoir se passer
d'elle pendant une dizaine de jours
alors vous perdez souvent d'un ou deux
buts dans le championnat
comment l'expliquez vous comment ça se
fait que les équipes souvent de qui
vient de l'extérieur vous battre à
domicile 2 1 ou 2 buts d'écart
l'inexpérience je pense je crois que la
dernière fois on s'est vus je vous avais
parlé de la marche qui était un petit
peu grande est monté de la nationale de
la nationale 1 en a je pense que le club
l'équipe n'a pas pris conscience un
petit peu de l'intérêt de s'entraîner
plus mieux de participer plus fort aux
entraînements et aujourd'hui on a un
déficit et ce déficit mais on essaie de
le combler mais la descente il reste
encore quinze points à prendre avant la
fin du championnat on n'y est pas tout à
fait encore montigny le bretonneux
handball féminin c'est pas la première
année que vous monter en nationale une
c'est avec d'autres entraîneurs par le
passé il y avait également eu une
relégation quasiment l'année qui a suivi
et la saison avait été très difficile en
n1 pourquoi le club n'arrive pas à
prendre conscience justement des
différences et de la marche et des
investissements peut-être nécessaire
aussi parce que ce n'est pas la première
fois ce n'est pas une découverte la
nationale in pour le club de montigny
absolument c'est pas une découverte mais
au fur et à mesure des années le niveau
donc les obligations le niveau
d'exigence donc augmente et c'est
peut-être là dessus qu'il faut se
calquer c'est peut-être message qu'il
faut passer aux plus jeunes dans le club
en terme de formation de préformation et
je crois que c'est au niveau de cette
marche là au niveau des plus jeunes
qu'il faut intervenir
il manque peut-être du physique
également l'équipe de montigny cette
saison vous parliez de fanny jean
baptiste qui avait été blessé sur le
dernier match
elle a été souvent blessé cette saison
quand l expliquez vous ben non c'est pas
c'est pas un problème physique c'est un
problème d'engagement et de morale vous
savez jusqu'à la 40e minute de chaque
match on fait quasi jeu égal avec toutes
les équipes c'est le contre lesquels en
tout cas moi j'ai joué jusqu'à présent
et puis l'équipe s'effondre donc c'est
psychologiquement les filles on peut à
raison de peur de mal faire les ballons
arrivent moins bien
c'est une expérience peut-être un petit
peu l'inexpérience et l'autre à clé le
tract l'obligation du résultat vous êtes
la plus mauvaise défense du championnat
de national cette saison
absolument les gens lui faudra
travailler encore un peu plus pour la
séance d'hier par exemple donc a été a
été consacrée exclusivement donc à tout
ça
on commence à travailler la vidéo donc
chose qui n'existait peut peu ou pas on
commence à travailler la vidéo donc et
je crois que ça commence à porter ses
fruits
il ya un problème peut-être de
professionnalisme dans le club au
professionnalisme on n'est pas prouvée
palin et vous êtes sévère mais un
défenseur très mauvaise défense n'est
pas professionnel oui non mais je
comprends parfaitement le sens de la
question on va pas + professionnalisme
mais en fait se structurent
effectivement et s'adapter au niveau
exigences ou du niveau et le départ de
philippe l'étrange qui a eu lieu au mois
de février at il lancé
l'ancien entraîneur l'ancien entraîneur
de mon team automne at il perturbé jeu
les joueurs je pense que c'est un
traumatisme changement d'entraîneur
c'est un traumatisme
on a on a beau dire le nouveau il va
faire mieux c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche en fait il a fallu absorber donc
sur traumatisme et se mettre ou se
remettre au travail et monty peut encore
se maintenir cette saison même si
l'équipe est pour l'instant dernière du
championnat finalement il n'y a que 1 ou
2 points d'écart avec avec les équipes
devant absolument 2.2.2 dekker donc mai
bien évidemment mathématiquement rien
n'est fait mais on est quand même aussi
obligé de penser au scénario catastrophe
consommez n'en ai pas et on commence a
déjà travaillé donc ou sur le maintien
ou sur l'allégation on n'est pas en
retard on sera pas en retard
vous êtes déjà sur le recrutement de
l'année prochaine absolument on est déjà
sur le trône de la saison prochaine donc
écrit où il y aura donc deux dossiers le
dossier albeau cbrc a déjà sollicité
certaines joueuses éventuellement pour
pour la montée et enfin pour le maintien
et puis en cas de relégation d'autres
joueurs c'est ça on a commencé comme
tous les clubs donc de national donne
donc on dira à contacter s'ils allaient
jouer la prospective a contacté des
joueuses affaires marché des réseaux
mais on a aussi commencé donc à nos plus
jeunes joueuses donc formé au club et
qu'on estime donc capable de jouer en
national devra commencer à leur donner
un petit peu de temps de jeu présence
aux entraînements et en compte aussi sur
ses joueuses
l'idée c'est d'avoir une équipe 100 %
local où emmener des équipes de
l'extérieur de l'île de france par
exemple
aujourd'hui on va favoriser donc le
local parce qu'on a des joueuses on a la
qualité sur place donc à montigny mais
si on devait faire venir une ou deux
joueuses se seraient des joueuses qui
nous amène à rien plus réel plus
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour la suite de la saison
on continuera à suivre avec attention
les résultats de motifs merci à vous
après on traverse l'océan et on parle de
baseball forge de comptines mais on
reste à montigny-le-bretonneux wilfried
les cougars qui évolue en deuxième
division russell ce dimanche équipe
fédérale de toulouse à domicile au stade
jean maréchal
le match est programmé à l'occasion de
la 3e journée du championnat les signé
montagne seront favorites face aux
favoris pardon lille n'avait pas fait de
détails en emportant leurs deux premiers
matchs de la saison 11 à 0 érigèrent je
me suis perdu je me suis perdu j'ai
perdu alors que les allées des fiches le
super la vie je n'ai pas prometteur
malheureusement les prix si vous avez
des filles se loger les fiches 11 à 0 et
10 à 5 contre les signes pour les
amateurs de danse wilfrid par exemple
offert la maternelle et des animations
avec le cheerleader sont organisées
juste avant la rencontre c'est un
véritable amateur de cheerleaders plus
jeunes et voilà dans l'audience
américaine sans véritablement dans
l'empiré américain et on termine cette
chronique par du football les invasions
excellence et un match très important où
wilfrid lui en cours saint quentin
reçoit les murs ou en match en retard du
championnat excellence les guyancourt
toi compte sur cette victoire pour
s'emparer de la deuxième place du
classement devant le chesnay attention
cette rencontre un double
je la deuxième place pourrait être
synonyme de montée si les gluants
courtois termine meilleur deuxième ils
ont donc tout intérêt à mettre de
l'intensité et a remporté la victoire
voilà wilfried vous connaissez tous les
rendez vous à ne pas manquer ce week-end
dans lé département j'espère que vous
avez noté de 2,3 date
oui en tout cas il y aura jean bataille
aura les résultats dès lundi sur tv fils
à 18h30 avec le 7-8 sport et puis ce
soir puisque nous sommes le jeudi
le talk si on parlait sport sur les
sports au g on parlera notamment de a
dit là où on m'a dit qui a perdu contre
kaloum smith donc sa ceinture de
champion d'europe d'europe voilà
champion d'europe tous âges vont aussi
vais vous suivez s'en fichent s'en fiche
mais on parlera également du centre de
clairefontaine qui a su bien un beau
lifting on peut le dire wilfried à 6
millions d'euros
pas mal pour impression de
clairefontaine pour les bleus pour
l'euro et karim benzama qui ne pourra
pas en profiter karim benzema qui pourra
pas exactement
merci michael c'est la fin est de cette
édition du journal on se retrouve demain
vendredi aux horaires habituels pour
l'essentiel et du jour et puis également
l'essentiel de la semaine les principaux
sujets que nous avons développée dans le
journal sur notre antenne depuis lundi
excellente soirée avec le talk sport
dans un instant